and let's get more on that breaking news
now that UEFA is to offer ticket refunds
for Liverpool fans who are affected by
unrest at last year's Champions League
final it comes as an investigation found
UEFA was mainly responsible for the
chaos that took place at the match in
Paris friends French police also faced
criticism for firing tear gas and pepper
spray indiscriminately Skies Sports
correspondent Rob Harris joins me now
from The Newsroom and Rob how many fans
were affected by this well it's over 19
000 Liverpool fans impacted in the chaos
in Paris last year and the UEFA are now
offering refunds to all those fans who
according to wafer's own official
investigation were nearly subjected to a
very serious event it talks about
potentially Mass casualties could have
happened at the Champions League final
at the stad de France given the chaotic
disorganization around the stadium
issues with the policing as well the
fact police were firing tear gas
indiscriminately which led to the
barriers being closed and also local
youths were trying to claim over the
fences to get into the stadium and
certainly there was a sense of a
disproportionate police response which
just created more scenes of chaos and
we're seeing the Liverpool fans who were
there last May who had legitimate
tickets who couldn't get into the
stadium were having their access denied
and on the night Liverpool fans were
accused of having responsibility for
trying to get in without tickets having
fake tickets something that UEFA and
French authorities later apologized for
and now this refund scheme which could
cost you a for millions of pounds as
they try to offer their own uh further
apologies and we do have a statement
from UA for today it reads we have taken
into account a huge number of views
Express both publicly and privately and
we believe we have devised a scheme that
is comprehensive and fair we recognize
that the negative experiences of those
supporters on the day and with this
scheme we will refund fans who have
bought tickets and who were the most
affected by the difficulties in
accessing the stadium as for the
supporters the spirit of shankly group
says this does not excuse you AFA exempt
them from criticism or lessen the need
for them to implement all of the
recommendations made by the independent
inquiry because there was a lot of fault
actually prescribed in this UEFA
investigation the independent report
Over The Faults the lack of full risk
assessment into the stadium into the
staging of the event the lack of
Staffing around the venue a lack of sort
of sense of Plan B for if anything did
go wrong for a game that eventually
started more than 30 minutes late and
inside the stat de France they were
blaming Liverpool fans for arriving late
as well so an overall picture of chaos
and attempt to blame Liverpool fans on
the Night by UEFA and the French
authorities but certainly the official
report completely exonerated Liverpool
fans in fact my experience there on the
Night in Paris was they were actually
trying to defuse the situation with
locals trying to stop them climbing over
fences to get in and now we know that
Liverpool fans will be offered complete
refunds for those who went to a match
but very much nearly and match that
ended in disaster nearly as the UEFA
report found